there's a dancer it's definitely like a
worst fear to be told you're never gonna
walk again but dance isn't about being
able to stand up dance is about from the
inside out expressing yourself I can
move with my body it was just different
to where I used to do my name is Mark
brewer and I'm the artistic director of
access dance company access dance
company is a physically integrated dance
company made up of dancers
with and without physical disabilities
it's about that combination of disabled
and non-disabled dancers and the unique
wonderful things that they do together
with these gestures in the dance world
when we say translation for example if I
had the choreographer he's showing me a
movement and their non-disabled down so
they're standing up how do I translate
what they're doing to my body once I'm
given a movement I take it and I look at
what she's doing with her body the
feeling she's trying to portray and then
I take that and I put it into how do I
make my chair feel and shift something
so just take your chest up choices
demarco for me is just so grounded and
humble he is an artist that the dancers
trust completely dancing I've given
myself over as very free and natural
I grew up in foster care and I got to a
point where not having things wasn't a
problem anymore I became like a level of
being free
[Music]
there's a moment where the audience
first sees a group that is consisted of
dancers with wheelchairs and for a brief
time that's all they see and they wonder
how they're gonna dance how is this
gonna happen you know
and then once they starting woman to me
with you people say the chair disappears
one day after performance at a young
child that came up to me admissibility
was also he using a wheelchair he said
to me I always wanted to dance and I
didn't think it was possible but after
seeing you I now know I can't
[Music]